welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and at the heart of the mysteries
of moon knight is the scarab doing its
best golden snitch impression while
containing a cryptic hieroglyphic code a
code that we began to decipher and now
thanks to actual egyptologists has been
deciphered bringing up fascinating
insights into the series and where it's
all headed i'm going to break down what
the experts have figured out and why
this revelation is so cool as we look
ahead to mark spector's fate on this
series and by the way the best way to
support new rockstars is to check out
our moon knight inspired tomb of the
moon god shirt that i am now wearing at
newrockstarsmerch.com and getting one of
these unlocks the added option of
writing the custom shout out for our
moon night after shows so moonite
episode 2 confirms that the scarab is a
compass that points to amit the scarab
pointing to ahmadu shakti what we fought
side my side for now an ushabti is a
funeral figurine placed among the items
that grave sites intended to act as
servants for the deceased to serve them
in the afterlife so this scarab compass
doesn't point to amit's tomb
specifically it really points to her
gravesite statue which might tell us
that amit is not entombed in a place but
rather entombed in one of these objects
as odin says asgard is not a place it's
a new shopkin after episode 1 i began to
try to decipher the hieroclypics carved
into the scarab and i was able to figure
out that the six columns are actually
three columns mirrored but it's not
really
one-to-one symbol to english letters so
thankfully a true expert on this dr dan
potter an egyptologist with the national
museums of scotland on twitter began to
translate it this brilliant expert
pointed out how that top symbol a read
as i said translates to an i but then
pointed out beside it is a man touching
his mouth which together translates to
the interjection of o and then beneath
that is a scarab symbol followed by the
open mouth which i was able to figure
out does translate to an r but then is
followed by another i in a seated figure
which all together translates to capri
which is the name of a god represented
by the scarab beetle who's associated
with the sun god for the way that
beetles roll a ball of their dung
ancient egyptians believed kepri rolled
the sun across the sky and then into the
underworld so then dr potter working
together with other egyptologists on
this thread like dr ken griffin of the
egypt center in wales completed the
translation to read the following o
capri amid his boat primeval one whose
corporeality is infinity or eternity may
you rescue osiris a menotep true a voice
and then dr griffin pointed out that
this is a passage taken directly from
the book of the dead chapter 17. now the
book of the dead refers to a loose
collection of texts compiled by ancient
egyptian priests over a period of a
thousand years that contains magic
spells intended to assist a deceased
person's journey through the underworld
essentially the process that stephen
described that creepy little girl in
episode one they believed you needed
your heart to be judged in the
underworld and only the worthiest would
be allowed to pass through the field of
reads and did it suck for you getting
rejected from the field of reads what if
that makes sense because i'm not dead am
i stevie
so the boat from the passage refers to
how the sky gods were depicted in boats
which was the primary form of
transportation in egypt up and down the
nile river and as stephen explained to
that girl upon your death your boat
would pass among the field of reeds
reeds that stuck up from the water now
the actual judgment is supposed to be
conducted by anubis who weighs your
heart upon scales against the weight of
a feather and if you are unworthy you
are fed to the beast on it but in heroes
cult amit is more of a deity figure
worshipped ahmed to be the one who holds
the scales in her mouth she claims that
judge responsibility for herself going
over anubis's head so the girl bullies
stephen saying that he was rejected from
this field of reads giving steven a
little panic attack and existential
crisis as he questions whether or not he
might be dead and as we continue to
question whether everything from
steven's perspective on the show is a
kind of allegorical illusion depicting a
deceased soul's passage through the
field of reeds into the underworld there
may be some clues pointing to this
possibility right now especially it
seems like the marvel cinematic universe
is really being inspired by the horror
genre so one of the best ways i'm
catching up on all these references is
by trying to watch as many scary movies
as i can and as the world's premiere
streaming service for horror thriller
and supernatural content shudder is a
necessity for fans of thrills and chills
sign up or shudder and get access to the
largest collection of binge-worthy
horror movies and series streamed right
to your favorite devices shutter gives
you unlimited access to the largest
fastest growing human curated selection
of thrilling and dangerous entertainment
ad-free for just 5.99 a month new
shockers and thrillers get added every
week and shutter works on your smart tv
xbox one apple tv or any other device
what we really like about shutter is
that they're always adding new titles to
their library the last time i logged on
they had just added evil dead one and
two and the vampire classic near dark
that's some awesome 80s horror and folks
headed into multiverse madness you
better check out sam randy's work for
evil dead it's just a great time to
check out shutter's great collection of
folk horror get rural and creepy with
classics like the wicker man and texas
chainsaw massacre or a deeper cut like
kill list they also have an exclusive
documentary woodlands dark and days
bewitched a history of folk horror so
get started streaming the best horror
thriller in supernatural content to try
shutter free for 30 days go to
shutter.com and use promo code new
rockstars that's
s-h-u-d-d-e-r.com and use promo code new
rockstars for a free 30-day trial and
gus's fish tank is a sunken one of these
boats as if its passenger never made it
through the field of reads and instead
plunged into the depths depth set in
episode 2 we see mark spector's ghostly
form submerged within and by the way the
occupant of this tank gus is replaced
suggesting he might have died and steven
didn't know it and that steven never
knows if the things seen in this tank
are alive or dead also gus i'm pretty
sure is short war sarcophagus the casket
for deceased egyptians now arthur harrow
is unable to judge steven's soul as if
he currently is not yet ready for this
assessment still in the reads and also
in episode two as he talks with leila
about that scarab in his apartment as
mark is depicted in the tank in front of
that fish tank is a crocodile figurine
like amet herself waiting to devour this
guilty heart now let's return to the
scare of translation the name amenitep
appears which means he was likely the
person who commissioned the scarab's
creation amenitep was the name of an
ancient egyptian pharaoh a minute of the
first being the second pharaoh of the
18th dynasty ruling from 1526 bc to 1506
bc amid except the first or one of its
descendants like a minute to the second
or minutes of the third could have been
that mystery original avatar who
betrayed amit whom ahmed gave the
crocodile staff that arthur harrow now
carries that contains a shred of amit's
power now future episodes may show a
literalized form of this mythologized
voyage on the boat because a new promo
showed clips of mark's original
possession by consho at the foot of the
statue a battle between moon knight and
harrow in front of the full moon and an
egyptian boat being paddled down a
purple tinted landscape but not
necessarily across water it looks like
sand dunes a boat that looks a lot like
the sunken one at the bottom of gus's
fish tank and the fact that this
landscape is purple suggests to me that
it could be the same place where harrow
summoned the jackal this being the
underworld of the mcu and i find it
interesting to be colored purple the
color of the heart-shaped herb in the
ancestral plain of wakanda whose panther
god boss is derived from the egyptian
feline deity of bastet purple also being
the color of dormammu in the dark
dimension and agatha's dark magic and
the purple rifts between realities in
spider-man no way home which wong
referred to as the dark border between
known and unknown realities i mean it
kind of feels like it's all connected
but you know it's just also stuff being
purple and again a huge special thanks
to dr dan potter and dr ken griffin and
all the brilliant egyptologists working
hard out there to figure out the
translation on that scarab because while
i try to make these videos as
educational as possible i just do not
have time to get an advanced degree in
egyptology hey a reminder to check out
this moon night inspired shirt at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at ea boss
following rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you